I was making myself, I was making myself this very fine hot chocolate. My first Mac hack was probably 88, so I was working at Orange Micro. There were some technical difficulties with the hot chocolate maker and I had to debug it. Guess what? I got a fever. And the only prescription is Sean Parent. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 17 recorded on March 18 2021. My name is Connor and today with my co host Bryce, we are super excited to bring you a conversation with our first guest, Sean Parent. How is it going, ADSP listeners? It is just Connor recording a introduction slash prologue
我当时正在给自己，给自己做一杯非常棒的热巧克力。我第一次接触 Mac 大概是在 88 年，当时我在 Orange Micro 工作。热巧克力机出了一些技术故障，我不得不调试它。你猜怎么着？我发烧了。唯一的处方就是 Sean Parent。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 17 期，录制于 2021 年 3 月 18 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，我们非常高兴能为大家带来与我们第一位嘉宾 Sean Parent 的对话。ADSP 的听众们，你们好吗？现在只有 Connor 在录制一段介绍/序言。
before we hop into the conversation with Sean. Sean Parent, as many of you know, is a senior principal scientist working for Adobe. He's been at Adobe since 1993, with the exception of a year in 2009 slash 2010, where he worked for Google, which is where the infamous That's a Rotate story comes from. Before Adobe, he worked at Apple for roughly five years. And before Apple, he started his career at a company called Orange Micro. That's all I'll say about Sean's work history as I'm sure you'll hear a lot more about it from him as he will be a recurring guest on ADSP the podcast. The one thing I do want to add though, is that if you haven't seen any of Sean's talks, I can't recommend them highly enough. My two favorites are C++ Seasoning from 2013 and Generic Programming from 2018. Listening to Sean talk is inspiring. And a part of the reason
在我们开始与 Sean 的对话之前。正如你们许多人所知，Sean Parent 是 Adobe 的高级首席科学家。他自 1993 年以来一直在 Adobe 工作，除了 2009/2010 年期间在 Google 工作了一年，那段经历也是著名的“那是 Rotate”故事的来源。在加入 Adobe 之前，他在 Apple 工作了大约五年。而在 Apple 之前，他的职业生涯始于一家名为 Orange Micro 的公司。关于 Sean 的工作经历我就说这么多，因为我相信你们会从他本人那里听到更多，他将成为 ADSP 播客的常驻嘉宾。不过，我确实想补充一点，如果你还没有看过 Sean 的任何演讲，我强烈推荐。我最喜欢的两个是 2013 年的《C++ Seasoning》和 2018 年的《Generic Programming》。听 Sean 演讲非常鼓舞人心。这也是我的一部分原因。
that I gave my first conference talk in 2019, Algorithm Intuition, is because of watching Sean Perrin's C++ seasoning from 2013. So at this point, I'm going to splice in a quote from his generic programming talk in 2018 because I think it's absolutely fantastic. And after that, we will hop into our conversation. Super excited to bring you this conversation with Sean Perrin. And Alex has this beautiful little solution in there for stable sort that builds it up out of all the other algorithms.
我在 2019 年做了我的第一次会议演讲《Algorithm Intuition》，就是因为看了 Sean Parent 2013 年的《C++ Seasoning》。所以现在，我要插入一段他 2018 年《Generic Programming》演讲中的引言，因为我觉得它非常精彩。在那之后，我们将开始我们的对话。非常高兴能为大家带来这次与 Sean Parent 的对话。Alex 在那里有一个非常漂亮的稳定排序（stable sort）解决方案，它是通过所有其他算法构建起来的。
All the algorithms within the STL fit together like puzzle pieces. I saw this and I thought, who writes code like this? Okay, right? I mean, keep in mind here, I'm working with a bunch of phenomenal engineers, right? Great people. These are some of the top people in the industry. And I've never seen somebody who writes code like this. Okay. This is not like the code that Alex published in, in his paper five years before, right? He's clearly grown and had some time to think about it. So it's just this phenomenal piece of work. And for me, it was like, like, I want to write code like that. How do I write code like that? All right, we are recording our first episode with a guest. And if you've been listening up till now, you probably have a good idea who it is, the man, the myth, the legend, Sean Parent. How's it going? Hey, it's going pretty good.
STL 中的所有算法就像拼图一样拼在一起。我看到这个时心想，谁会写出这样的代码？对吧？我的意思是，请记住，我当时和一群杰出的工程师一起工作，对吧？都是很棒的人。他们是业内顶尖的人才。但我从未见过有人能写出这样的代码。好吧。这不像 Alex 五年前在他论文中发表的代码，对吧？他显然成长了，并且有时间去思考它。所以这真是一部了不起的作品。对我来说，就像是，我想写出那样的代码。我该如何写出那样的代码？好了，我们正在录制我们的第一期嘉宾访谈。如果你一直听到这里，你可能已经猜到他是谁了，那个男人，那个神话，那个传奇，Sean Parent。你好吗？嘿，我很好。
So yeah, I've been actually listening to your podcast. I think I'm current, so I've listened to all of them. It was probably the highlight of my year so far when you tweeted out around Christmas the photo of you with a glass of eggnog with the caption, that was a lot of APL. So thank you for that. Yeah, you're an easy man to please i guess so sean do you do you remember your do you remember the keynote you gave at c++ now like 2014 it was a it was you gave a talk where you were talking about getting Photoshop or something of that nature running on an iPad.
所以，是的，我其实一直在听你们的播客。我想我已经跟上进度了，所以我把所有的都听完了。大概是我今年到目前为止最开心的时刻，就是圣诞节前后你发推特晒出你拿着一杯蛋酒的照片，配文是“那是很多 APL”。所以谢谢你。是的，我想你是个很容易满足的人。那么 Sean，你还记得你在 C++ Now 大会上的主题演讲吗？大概是 2014 年，你做了一个演讲，谈到了让 Photoshop 或类似的东西在 iPad 上运行。
And what I remember about the talk is there's one part where you're talking about what's the compute that you have available on the iPad. And like a small part of it is the serial processing power. And then there's a larger part of it that's the, you know, parallel processing power. And then you have the GPU. And yeah, it was just, I think it's my favorite of your talks. But anyways, I've been thinking about it a lot lately because i now obviously work at nvidia and work a lot on parallel computing and uh i just remember net like like in hindsight thinking that talk was really prescient yeah it's uh i use that slide that slides actually from from russell williams and it's it's not specific to the ipad it's actually uh an intel box that a few years ago he kind of broke down the numbers on but yeah if you look at where the compute horsepower is and in a
我记得演讲中有一部分是你谈到了 iPad 上可用的计算能力。其中一小部分是串行处理能力。然后有一大部分是，你知道，并行处理能力。然后你还有 GPU。是的，我觉得这是我最喜欢你的演讲之一。但无论如何，我最近一直在思考这个问题，因为我现在显然在 NVIDIA 工作，做了很多并行计算方面的工作，呃，我只是记得事后回想起来，那个演讲非常有远见。是的，那张幻灯片其实是 Russell Williams 的，它并不是专门针对 iPad 的，实际上是几年前他拆解的一台 Intel 机器的数据，但如果你看看计算能力在哪里，在现代机器中，如果你只是在写……
modern machine if you're just writing.25% of the complete compute capability of the machine. And most of the MIPS are trapped inside the GPU and increasingly now split between GPU and ML units. Yeah. Yeah, one of these days I'm going to, one of these days somebody at NVIDIA is going to teach me something about this machine learning stuff. Yeah. Yeah, definitely worth looking at. I mean, the, you know, my short summary of kind of modern machine learning is is
机器总计算能力的 25%。大部分 MIPS 都被困在 GPU 中，现在越来越多地在 GPU 和 ML 单元之间分配。是的。是的，总有一天，总有一天 NVIDIA 的某个人会教我一些关于机器学习的东西。是的。是的，绝对值得一看。我的意思是，你知道，我对现代机器学习的简短总结是……
if you think about you know what we write on machines are just functions and and we typically come up with some equation for the function but any function can be approximated and so if you have something where you don't know what the function is, but you can feed enough material to a machine learning system, it can learn to derive an approximate function. And so, you know, that's kind of all machine learning is, but it does change things. If you look at image processing, say, take Lightroom, the Lightroom auto button, which, you know, kind of auto-adjusts all the sliders. That used to be a very carefully hand-tuned algorithm and trying to look at, well, you know, statistically,
如果你想想，你知道，我们在机器上编写的只是函数，我们通常会为函数想出一些方程，但任何函数都可以被近似。所以如果你有一些你不知道函数是什么的东西，但你可以向机器学习系统输入足够的材料，它就能学会推导出一个近似函数。所以，你知道，这就是机器学习的全部内容，但它确实改变了事情。如果你看看图像处理，比如 Lightroom，Lightroom 的自动按钮，你知道，它会自动调整所有的滑块。那曾经是一个非常精心手工调整的算法，试图去观察，嗯，你知道，从统计学上讲，
how would we want to balance highlights and shadows, and what about this kind of image, and what about that kind of image? And the approach now is to just get a bunch of experts and have them correct a whole bunch of images and do a really good job and have the machine learn what they do. And that's the auto button these days. So you've worked on Photoshop. What are all the things that you've worked on in Adobe?
我们如何平衡高光和阴影，这种图像怎么样，那种图像又怎么样？而现在的方法是找一群专家，让他们校正一大堆图像，做得非常好，然后让机器学习他们的做法。这就是现在的自动按钮。所以你做过 Photoshop。你在 Adobe 还做过什么？
You've worked on Photoshop, Premiere? I have not worked on Premiere. So at Adobe, I started at Adobe working on Photoshop and then we launched an internet division. This was way back when Netscape was really hot and everybody needed an internet division. And so I ended up working on a shared component about the only surviving piece of that is something called XMP, which is a standard for metadata and how metadata is embedded in documents so that you can pull it out. From there I did a stint in Adobe's ATG, which is their advanced technology group, or was at the time, a research team.
你做过 Photoshop，Premiere？我没有做过 Premiere。在 Adobe，我最初是在做 Photoshop，然后我们成立了一个互联网部门。那是在 Netscape 非常火的时候，每个人都需要一个互联网部门。所以我最终在一个共享组件上工作，其中唯一幸存的部分是名为 XMP 的东西，它是一个元数据标准，以及元数据如何嵌入到文档中以便你可以提取它。从那里，我在 Adobe 的 ATG 工作了一段时间，也就是他们当时的先进技术组，一个研究团队。
And I was doing, that's where I started research on something called property models, which I still, is still something that I continue to work on in my, what little spare time I have. While I was in ATG is when Adobe hired and then fired Alex Stepanoff and that led to me and then hired him back and the hiring him back led to me managing him and together we formed Adobe Software Technology Lab which spun out of our research team and so we formed Adobe Software Technology Lab, which spun out of our research team. And so I ran Adobe Software Technology Lab for eight years. And, you know, we wrote the book Elements of Programming. We created Adobe Source Libraries. We did a whole bunch of stuff internally as part of that effort.
我当时正在做，那是我开始研究名为属性模型（property models）的东西的地方，这仍然是我在仅有的业余时间里继续研究的东西。当我在 ATG 时，Adobe 聘请了然后又解雇了 Alex Stepanov，这导致我后来又把他聘请回来，聘请他回来让我管理他，我们一起组建了 Adobe 软件技术实验室（Adobe Software Technology Lab），它从我们的研究团队中分离出来。所以我们组建了 Adobe 软件技术实验室，它从我们的研究团队中分离出来。我经营了 Adobe 软件技术实验室八年。而且，你知道，我们写了《Elements of Programming》这本书。我们创建了 Adobe 源代码库。我们作为该努力的一部分在内部做了很多事情。
And when STLAB fell apart, I went to Google for a year, worked on Chrome OS, came back to Adobe to work on Revel, which was a consumer version of Lightroom for, we shipped it for iPhone, iPad, and desktop and it was a precursor for Lightroom Mobile. It was running the same imaging engine that Lightroom runs and so I pivoted from working on Revel just before Revel was cancelled to start Lightroom Mobile and so I did Lightroom Mobile and then got the imaging engine going inside the browser. So that was Lightroom Web. And then after doing that, a guy named Dave Howell walked into my office one day and said, could we just put Photoshop on the iPad?
当 STLAB 解散时，我去了 Google 工作了一年，负责 Chrome OS，然后回到 Adobe 负责 Revel，这是 Lightroom 的消费者版本，我们为 iPhone、iPad 和桌面发布了它，它是 Lightroom Mobile 的前身。它运行着与 Lightroom 相同的成像引擎，所以在 Revel 被取消之前，我从 Revel 转到了 Lightroom Mobile，所以我做了 Lightroom Mobile，然后让成像引擎在浏览器中运行。那就是 Lightroom Web。在那之后，一个叫 Dave Howell 的人有一天走进我的办公室说，我们能把 Photoshop 放到 iPad 上吗？
And I said, I think I know how I would do that. And that launched the effort to put Photoshop on iPad. So I did Photoshop mobile. And Photoshop mobile is somewhat of a larger effort. You can probably read the tea leaves if you look at people we're hiring these days. But part of that was taking the Photoshop codebase and turning it into a library that contains kind of all the interactive logic. So you can't just do batch processing with it, but you can attach a UI to this library and put Photoshop in other places. And so recently I've been doing some work putting Photoshop in other places which haven't shipped yet. And right now I'm
我说，我想我知道我该怎么做。于是启动了将 Photoshop 放到 iPad 上的工作。所以我做了 Photoshop mobile。Photoshop mobile 是一个相当大的工程。如果你看看我们最近雇佣的人，你可能能读懂其中的玄机。但其中一部分是将 Photoshop 代码库变成一个包含所有交互逻辑的库。所以你不能只用它进行批处理，但你可以将 UI 附加到这个库上，并将 Photoshop 放在其他地方。所以最近我一直在做一些将 Photoshop 放在其他地方的工作，这些工作还没有发布。现在我正在……
putting together a white paper and maybe looking to hire somebody and get back in the research side of things a little bit. I've got an idea for a potential product that's a little bit long I've got an idea for a potential product that's a little bit long lead and is going to require a little research to feed into it. Spicy. So when did you first meet Alex? Did you know Stepanov before you became his manager?
整理一份白皮书，也许想雇个人，重新回到研究方面。我有一个潜在产品的想法，周期有点长，需要一些研究来支撑它。很刺激。那么你第一次见到 Alex 是什么时候？在你成为他的经理之前，你认识 Stepanov 吗？
Yes, yeah. So when I was working in Adobe's ATG group, one of my colleagues there was an individual, Larry Macenter. And Larry had worked with Alex at Bell Labs years ago and was friends with Alex and Larry invited Alex to give a talk at Adobe and at that time Alex was vice president at Compaq computers if you remember who they were they made kind of you know portable PC devices and Compaq was getting bought out by hp and so alex had been in hp research before but now he's a vp at compact going through a transition to hewlett packard and so alex came in and gave a talk on stl and afterwards i went up to him and told him hey enjoyed the talk and a fan of your work on STL.
是的，是的。当我在 Adobe 的 ATG 组工作时，我的同事之一是 Larry Macenter。Larry 多年前在贝尔实验室和 Alex 一起工作过，是 Alex 的朋友，Larry 邀请 Alex 到 Adobe 做演讲。当时 Alex 是 Compaq 电脑的副总裁，如果你还记得他们是谁的话，他们制造便携式 PC 设备，Compaq 当时正被 HP 收购，所以 Alex 之前在 HP 研究院工作过，但现在他是 Compaq 的副总裁，正在经历向 Hewlett Packard 的过渡，所以 Alex 进来做了关于 STL 的演讲，之后我走过去告诉他，嘿，很喜欢你的演讲，我是你 STL 工作的粉丝。
And it was a wonderful talk. And he asked what I did. And we started chatting about at the time I was researching property models. And he said, you know, that's actually interesting. So we ended up going up to my office and talking for like four hours. And I gave him a demo of property models, and we just chatted. And at some point in that conversation, he said, he said, you know, I've really missed being an engineer and doing engineering. And I said, well, why don't you go back to it?
那是一场精彩的演讲。他问我是做什么的。我们开始聊天，当时我正在研究属性模型。他说，你知道，这其实很有趣。所以我们最终去了我的办公室聊了大约四个小时。我给他演示了属性模型，我们只是聊天。在谈话的某个时刻，他说，他说，你知道，我真的很怀念做工程师和从事工程工作。我说，好吧，为什么不回去做呢？
Like, what's stopping you? And he just kind of laughed and shrugged it off. And, you know, we wrapped up our talk and he went away. And about two weeks later, he gave me a call and said, you know, I gave a lot of thought to what you were saying. And I would like to go back and be an engineer. And is there a position at Adobe? And I tried to get him a position in Adobe's research organization, but failed. In fact, the exact quote I got from our then CTO was, we don't need another C++ person like you.
是什么在阻碍你？他只是笑了笑，耸了耸肩。然后，你知道，我们结束了谈话，他离开了。大约两周后，他给我打电话说，你知道，我认真考虑了你所说的话。我想回去做一名工程师。Adobe 有职位吗？我试图为他在 Adobe 的研究组织中争取一个职位，但失败了。事实上，我从我们当时的 CTO 那里得到的原话是：“我们不需要另一个像你这样的 C++ 人。”
To put this in context a little bit, at the time, there was this belief that Adobe would at some point rewrite all of their applications, either in Java or in Flash, as safer languages. So I never thought that that would ever happen, and certainly I've been proven correct to date. But I did manage to find Alex a position in one of our shared technology groups, and unfortunately it was a really bad mismatch. This was kind of generally a mediocre team. There were some strong individuals on the team working on a legacy component that just needed a bunch of bug fixes and maintenance. And Alex came in and was of
为了说明一下背景，当时有一种信念，认为 Adobe 会在某个时候用 Java 或 Flash 作为更安全的语言重写他们所有的应用程序。所以我从没想过这会发生，当然，事实证明我是对的。但我确实设法在我们的一个共享技术组中为 Alex 找到了一个职位，不幸的是，这是一个非常糟糕的错配。这通常是一个平庸的团队。团队里有一些强人正在维护一个遗留组件，只需要进行一些错误修复和维护。Alex 进来后认为……
the opinion that you know basically all of this is wrong and needs to be rewritten from the ground up. And the engineers on this team don't have a strong theoretical education. So I need to start by teaching the engineers how to code. And then we'll start rewriting this product. That went over about as well with management as you would expect and and we tried hard. We tried to make the classes very relevant and you know I helped Alex with his classes and Alex was getting increasingly frustrated and and at one point I told Alex I said you
基本上这一切都是错的，需要从头开始重写。而这个团队的工程师没有扎实的理论教育。所以我需要从教工程师如何写代码开始。然后我们将开始重写这个产品。管理层对这件事的反应正如你所料，我们尝试了。我们努力让课程变得非常相关，你知道，我帮助 Alex 准备他的课程，Alex 越来越沮丧，有一次我告诉 Alex，我说，你知道……
know if it gets to the point where you're going to quit, please call me and we'll see if there's something else that, you know, see if we can make something else happen. And he said, no, no, no. He thought that this project was important and he was willing to stick it out and there was no way he was going to quit. And about two weeks later, he called me up and he goes willing to stick it out and there was no way he was going to quit. And about two weeks later, he called me up and he goes, guess what? And I said, you quit. And he's like, no, they fired me. And so I went to my then boss, who was Greg Gilley,
如果到了你要辞职的地步，请打电话给我，我们看看能不能做点别的，看看能不能促成别的事情。他说，不，不，不。他认为这个项目很重要，他愿意坚持下去，他绝不会辞职。大约两周后，他打电话给我，他说，愿意坚持下去，他绝不会辞职。大约两周后，他打电话给我，他说，猜怎么着？我说，你辞职了？他说，不，他们解雇了我。所以我去找我当时的老板 Greg Gilley，
and a lot of respect for Greg and said you know Alex was fired and you need to to make that not happen and hire him back into your organization and Greg said I can't do that politically because he was you know fired in a different organization and it makes the management chain in that organization look bad if I then just turn around and hire him back. And I said, well, at least do me a favor and take Alex out to lunch. So Greg took Alex out to lunch and came back and called me into his office and said, damn you, I'm going to hire him back.
我对 Greg 很尊重，我说 Alex 被解雇了，你需要让这件事不要发生，把他重新雇回你的组织。Greg 说，我在政治上做不到，因为他是在另一个组织被解雇的，如果我转过身来把他雇回来，会让那个组织的管理链看起来很糟糕。我说，好吧，至少帮我个忙，带 Alex 去吃午饭。所以 Greg 带 Alex 去吃了午饭，回来后把我叫进他的办公室说，该死，我要把他雇回来。
But here's the deal. You're going to manage him. Had you managed people before Alex? So, yeah, I had been an engineering manager on Photoshop for a while fairly early on during Photoshop 5 timeframe and when I had done the stint with when we launched the Internet division I was managing a shared technology team in that organization. So I had done some amount of management.
但条件是，你要管理他。在 Alex 之前你管理过人吗？是的，我在 Photoshop 5 时期很早就做过一段时间的工程经理，当我们推出互联网部门时，我管理着该组织的一个共享技术团队。所以我做过一些管理工作。
But I'm going to bet that Alex was a bit different. You know, yes, Alex was a bit different. My wife will sometimes refer to me as Peter Pan because I have a habit of collecting the lost boys, is the way she puts it. You know, when I was running Software Technology Lab, myself included, almost everybody on the team except for Alex were kind of refugees from our advanced technology group and so kind of, you know, misfit individuals. Even when I was engineering manager on Photoshop, my management philosophy has always been that, you know, you kind of want to align your goals with where the company is going,
但我敢打赌 Alex 有点不同。你知道，是的， Alex 确实有点不同。我妻子有时会称我为彼得·潘，因为我有一种收集“迷失男孩”的习惯，她是这么说的。你知道，当我经营软件技术实验室时，包括我在内，团队中除了 Alex 以外的几乎每个人都是我们先进技术组的难民，所以，你知道，是不合群的人。即使当我担任 Photoshop 的工程经理时，我的管理理念也一直是，你知道，你想要将你的目标与公司的发展方向保持一致，
but you want people to be working on what interests them. And sometimes that means not taking a straight line path to what the corporate goals are. It means you'll run a bit on a tangent. But if you have your people working on things that interest them, you'll end up going further faster than if you just force people to stay on target and walk a straight line. So I'm a relatively hands-off manager when it comes to the individuals. I try to just make sure that I'm communicating with them well and know what they're doing and know what they're working on. Largely the role then for me of being a manager is conveying that information up,
但你希望人们从事他们感兴趣的工作。有时这意味着不走直线去实现公司目标。这意味着你会偏离一点。但如果你让人们从事他们感兴趣的事情，你最终会比强迫人们保持目标并走直线走得更远。所以当涉及到个人时，我是一个相对放手的经理。我只是尽量确保我与他们沟通良好，知道他们在做什么，知道他们在研究什么。对我来说，作为经理的角色主要是向上级传达这些信息，
making sure that management is aware of the value of the team and that things are going well in that regard. I just realized we should probably explain to our audience who Alex Stepanov is because some of our listeners are not going to be C++ people and won't know. Right, so who is Alex Stepanov? Right, so Alex Stepanov, best known as the creator of the STL, the Standard Template Library, which is part of the C++ Standard Library,
确保管理层意识到团队的价值，并且在这方面进展顺利。我刚意识到我们应该向我们的听众解释 Alex Stepanov 是谁，因为我们的一些听众不是 C++ 人，不会知道。好吧，那么 Alex Stepanov 是谁？好吧，Alex Stepanov，最出名的是 STL（标准模板库）的创建者，它是 C++ 标准库的一部分，
which was very unique and revolutionary at the time that it became part of the C++ standard. It didn't look like any other library in that time frame. And part of that was inventing the notion of concepts, which are now a formal part of the language in C++20. So Alex wrote the early papers and coined the term concept. You know, Alex's history, he's quite a brilliant individual. He was born and raised in Moscow, was a Ph. the 70s and found his way to the US worked mostly in research organizations in GE labs Bell labs, HP labs, doing research in software development. And it was his stint at Bell labs that got him interested in C and C++ languages. And then he developed the standard template library at HP Labs.
这在它成为 C++ 标准一部分时是非常独特和革命性的。它看起来不像那个时期的任何其他库。其中一部分是发明了概念（concepts）的概念，现在它们是 C++20 中语言的正式组成部分。所以 Alex 写了早期的论文并创造了“概念”这个词。你知道，Alex 的历史，他是一个非常聪明的人。他在莫斯科出生长大，是 70 年代的博士，后来到了美国，主要在 GE 实验室、贝尔实验室、HP 实验室从事软件开发研究。正是他在贝尔实验室的经历让他对 C 和 C++ 语言产生了兴趣。然后他在 HP 实验室开发了标准模板库。
So I didn't know Stepanov was kicked out of Russia. I had not heard that before. Are you allowed to elaborate or shine some light on what happened there, or is that something we don't talk about anymore? You know, I've gotten the story from Alex, so apologies if I don't get all the details correct here. And that gave him access to foreign diplomats who were visiting Moscow. And he would smuggle information to the foreign diplomats and was arrested twice by the KGB. The first time he was sentenced to military service, and the second time they... it was more of punitive measures. And the third time he was caught,
所以我不知道 Stepanov 是被赶出俄罗斯的。我以前没听说过。你方便详细说明一下或者讲讲发生了什么吗，还是说那是不再谈论的事情？你知道，我是从 Alex 那里听来的故事，所以如果我没有把所有细节都弄对，请见谅。这让他有机会接触到访问莫斯科的外国外交官。他会向外国外交官走私信息，并被克格勃逮捕了两次。第一次他被判服兵役，第二次他们……更多是惩罚性措施。第三次他被抓时，
they escorted him to the border, stripped him of his papers, he and his wife, and said goodbye. So, yes, he was, I believe it was Austria. He was stuck in Austria for some amount of time, and he had friends in Sweden. So he was trying to get permission to leave to Sweden, and just because of the bureaucracy, he couldn't make that happen. And one of his contacts said,
他们把他护送到边境，剥夺了他的证件，他和他的妻子，然后说了再见。所以，是的，他，我相信是奥地利。他在奥地利被困了一段时间，他在瑞典有朋友。所以他试图获得去瑞典的许可，但由于官僚主义，他没能做到。他的一位联系人说，
you know, you need to contact the U.S. And apparently the U.S. was like a Russian mathematician. You want to come to the U.S.? Yep, we'll make that happen. So this was in the middle of the Cold War. And so that's how he ended up in the U.S. Well, Connor's dad is also a journalist So that's how he ended up in the U.S. Connor's dad is also a journalist and apparently a fairly well-known journalist in Canada.
你知道，你需要联系美国。显然美国当时就像是“一个俄罗斯数学家？你想来美国？是的，我们会促成这件事。”所以这正值冷战时期。这就是他最终来到美国的原因。好吧，Connor 的父亲也是一名记者，所以这就是他最终来到美国的原因。Connor 的父亲也是一名记者，显然在加拿大是一位相当出名的记者。
That is true, yes. Didn't you want to tell me, Connor, that you used to have people who would look at your last name and their faces would pale and they'd be like, are you related to whatever your dad's name is's name yeah this is a super random anecdote that probably our listeners uh won't care about um one time at a party um when i was in university yeah i met one of my my ex's friends and they said oh hookstra that's uh you're not related to gourd which is my dad's name, are you? And I said, oh, yeah, that's my dad. And then she was just like, can you get me a meeting with him? And I was like, for what? And she's like, I work for Fortis, which is like an oil company.
那是真的，是的。Connor，你不是想告诉我，你过去常有那种人，他们看着你的姓氏，脸色苍白，然后问：“你和那个谁谁谁有关系吗？”是的，这是一个超级随机的轶事，我们的听众可能不会关心……有一次在大学的一个聚会上，我遇到了我前任的一个朋友，他们说：“哦，Hookstra，你和 Gourd（我父亲的名字）没关系吧？”我说：“哦，是的，那是我爸爸。”然后她就说：“你能帮我安排和他见个面吗？”我说：“为了什么？”她说：“我在 Fortis 工作，那是一家石油公司。”
And they were like, it would be, oh, my goodness, like the people upstairs, like there's flags, red flags. They get raised whenever, you know, he sends out a story that has anything to do with us. And anyway, so it's he was an investigative reporter. So if you were doing anything sketchy in Canada, you'd be afraid of the sky. Yeah. Yeah. So I just think of him as like my dad. But to people that work at oil companies and to politicians, they're they're always there's a bit of concern i think when uh when and i'm glad that there's probably like zero overlap between everyone that i'm talking about right now and the people that listen to this podcast but anyways um yeah well don't worry i think it's pretty
他们说：“这会是，天哪，楼上的人，有红旗。每当他发出任何与我们有关的故事时，他们就会警觉起来。”总之，他是一名调查记者。所以如果你在加拿大做任何可疑的事情，你都会害怕这个人。是的。是的。所以我只是把他当作我的爸爸。但对于在石油公司工作的人和政客来说，我想当……我很高兴我刚才提到的所有人与听这个播客的人之间可能零重叠，但无论如何……是的，好吧，别担心，我想……
unlikely that he's going to get kicked out of canada for sure yeah but that is crazy that um i did not and that's it's so weird to think that Stepan, like we all, or at least I, we think of him as sort of like the father of the, you know, standard template library. And, you know, worked at Adobe for a number of years, that at one point, he was being sort of chased down by the KGB. And then at some point, they said, bye-bye uh i mean i i really kind of think of him as not not only the father of the standard template library but also also sort of the the father of a lot of what we consider to be you know modern c++ library design um you know a lot of a lot of the um a lot of the fundamentals that we take for granted about how you should build a C++ library come from work that Alex either did or Alex inspired. Yeah, I think that's definitely true. I think, unfortunately, you know, I'm going to say this because I'm working on a standards proposal right now. I just finished a couple pages for John Lagos's upcoming book. But I'm working on a standards proposal to try to fix the postconditions of a move from object in the standard,
他因为这个被赶出加拿大的可能性很小。是的，但这太疯狂了，我不知道，想到 Stepanov，我们所有人，或者至少我，我们认为他是标准模板库之父，在 Adobe 工作了多年，在某个时候，他曾被克格勃追捕。然后在某个时候，他们说，再见。我的意思是，我真的不仅认为他是标准模板库之父，而且也是我们认为的许多现代 C++ 库设计的父亲……你知道，我们认为理所当然的关于如何构建 C++ 库的许多基本原理都来自 Alex 所做或启发的工作。是的，我认为这绝对是真的。我认为，不幸的是，你知道，我要说出来，因为我正在制定一个标准提案。我刚刚为 John Lagos 即将出版的书写了几页。但我正在制定一个标准提案，试图修复标准中移动对象后的后置条件，
which I think are badly broken. But in kind of digging through why the postconditions for a move from object are badly broken, it, you know, I realized that one of the key ideas from STL and concepts which was about the domain of an operation, has been all but stripped from STL. And the requirements in the standard right now, even though we still have the requirements tables where we define things like, you know, what equality comparable is or what less than comparable is, and now they're called things like you know CPP 17 equality comparable. We have all the tables there as STL requirements but they're no longer actually used as requirements. So if you look you know
我认为它们被严重破坏了。但在挖掘为什么移动对象后的后置条件被严重破坏的原因时，我意识到 STL 和概念中的一个关键思想，即关于操作域（domain of an operation）的思想，几乎已经从 STL 中被剥离了。标准中现在的要求，即使我们仍然有定义诸如“相等可比较”或“小于可比较”之类的要求表，现在它们被称为诸如“CPP 17 相等可比较”之类的东西。我们有所有的表作为 STL 要求，但它们不再被实际用作要求。所以如果你看……
if you if you just search the the standard for the the CPP 17 equality comparable requirement it's never used as a requirement for any of the algorithms or containers right stood find doesn't require that the value type is equality comparable anymore where it did in the old old STL documentation. Instead there's just a couple of types within the standard library that satisfy the requirements that you know they guarantee they satisfy the requirements of of a quality comparable as my example here. But that's you know what value does that have if nothing actually has the requirement, right? I have a type that satisfies these requirements that nothing
如果你搜索标准中的“CPP 17 相等可比较”要求，它从未被用作任何算法或容器的要求，对吧？std::find 不再要求值类型是相等可比较的，而在旧的 STL 文档中是要求的。相反，标准库中只有几种类型满足这些要求，它们保证满足“相等可比较”的要求，作为我的例子。但如果没有任何东西实际有这个要求，那有什么价值呢？我有一个满足这些要求的类型，但没有任何东西……
actually requires. So, I think over time the semantics of the standard library have kind of been stripped away, and what we're left with is works as coded. When I write std find, it's defined as it applies equal equal to each of the elements in the sequence until equal equals returns true. And at that point, equal equal is just a predicate it's not it's not actually searching for for an equal element yeah this has been um this is actually a problem i've i've become intimately familiar with um because i did a lot of work on the algorithms when we were adding the parallel versions of the algorithms, we came to realize that a lot of the specification of the requirements for some of the algorithms, notably the numeric ones, but some of the others as well,
实际要求它。所以，我认为随着时间的推移，标准库的语义已经被剥离了，剩下的只是“按代码工作”。当我写 std::find 时，它的定义是对序列中的每个元素应用“==”，直到“==”返回 true。在那一点上，“==”只是一个谓词，它实际上并不是在搜索一个相等的元素。是的，这实际上是一个我已经非常熟悉的问题，因为当我们在添加算法的并行版本时，我做了很多关于算法的工作，我们意识到一些算法的要求规范，特别是数值算法，但其他一些也是如此，
were sort of underspecified or didn't really capture all of what the requirements were. And in many cases, they didn't, you know, we didn't have concepts in the language when we first introduced them and we didn't get them in C++11. And so because of that, the current corpus of algorithms, the ones that have been there since, you know, since the start are not specified in terms of concepts, which is unfortunate. Eric Niebler likes to say that concepts should come from algorithms, right? That you write the
要么说明不足，要么没有真正捕捉到所有的要求。在许多情况下，当我们第一次引入它们时，语言中没有概念，我们在 C++11 中也没有得到它们。因此，当前的算法库，那些从一开始就在那里的算法，并没有用概念来指定，这很不幸。Eric Niebler 喜欢说概念应该来自算法，对吧？你编写……
concepts that a particular algorithm needs. But unfortunately, that's just not how the, that's not how the specification is structured today, although we've gone a long way till it's fixing that with ranges. Yeah, I, you know, I think things are improved in ranges, although we don't, in C++20 anyways, we don't have much in the terms of algorithms with ranges. I haven't looked at what's going on with C++23, you know, where we where we might get more. But yes, it is it is very unfortunate and it's been you know, kind of this this this I
特定算法需要的概念。但不幸的是，现在的规范结构不是那样的，尽管我们通过 ranges 在修复这个问题上走了很长一段路。是的，我认为 ranges 有所改进，尽管在 C++20 中，我们在 ranges 算法方面没有太多东西。我还没有看 C++23 的进展，你知道，我们可能会得到更多。但是的，这非常不幸，而且这已经……
think this, I think, thing that has happened over time, this weakening of the concepts, because people want to say, well, look, if I call find, and find is just this loop, and I call it with my equal equal, it does what I want. It may not do, you know,
我认为随着时间的推移，这种概念的弱化已经发生，因为人们想说，好吧，看，如果我调用 find，而 find 只是这个循环，我用我的“==”调用它，它做了我想要的。它可能没有做……
it may not be completely legal, but what I want happens to have the same structure. And the way things are defined right now, it's perfectly legitimate to call std find, say, where the value you're looking for is a NAND. And that won't actually find anything, but it's completely legal as far as the standard's concerned, because you can call operator equal on all the things. So even if you're looking for an and in the sequence of NAMs, you can call it, it won't find it.
它可能不完全合法，但我想要的恰好有相同的结构。按照目前的定义，调用 std::find 是完全合法的，比如，你寻找的值是 NaN。那实际上找不到任何东西，但就标准而言，它是完全合法的，因为你可以在所有东西上调用 operator==。所以即使你在 NaN 序列中寻找 NaN，你也可以调用它，它找不到它。
Where in, say, the HP or the SGI STL, the early versions of STL, and even in the early versions of the standard, that would have been undefined behavior because you were violating the preconditions for find. And over time, the preconditions have been weakened. And along with that, the semantics of the operation have been weakened. I think a part of it is also we often at the surface,
而在 HP 或 SGI STL，即 STL 的早期版本，甚至在标准的早期版本中，那将是未定义行为，因为你违反了 find 的前置条件。随着时间的推移，前置条件被削弱了。随之而来的是，操作的语义也被削弱了。我认为部分原因也是我们经常在表面上，
we think about concept requirements as being syntactic, but there's also semantic requirements too. And it's often difficult or impossible for us to enforce the semantic requirements, but it does not make them any less important. Yeah, yeah. And that's the point. It doesn't make them any less important. Yeah, yeah. And that's the point. It doesn't make them any less important. And the whole idea, you know, with concepts was they've never been particularly checkable because for the most part, you know, they rely on existential qualifiers, right? You know, for all or for any, you know, I'm sorry, for all or there exists, right, right, right, right, some element that satisfies this. And so there's no way short of doing a proof that you can validate that that's
我们认为概念要求是句法上的，但也有语义要求。我们通常很难或不可能强制执行语义要求，但这并不意味着它们不重要。是的，是的。这就是重点。这并不意味着它们不重要。是的，是的。这就是重点。这并不意味着它们不重要。整个想法，你知道，关于概念，它们从来都不是特别可检查的，因为在大多数情况下，你知道，它们依赖于存在量词，对吧？你知道，对于所有或对于任何，你知道，抱歉，对于所有或存在，对吧，对吧，对吧，对吧，满足此条件的某个元素。所以除了做证明之外，没有办法验证这一点……
met. So the idea with concepts was to say, we can still have the strict semantics. And what we do is we just associate those semantics with a name. If you use this name, then you have to guarantee that you satisfy these semantics. And if you do satisfy those semantics, then the operation works as specified. But yeah, so over time, those semantics have been stripped away. So like I said, stood fine no longer requires equality. It only requires that operator of that, you know, a lot of these concepts, a lot of the concepts or things you want to say I want an invocable that can take a single parameter that is an integral. So not a particular instance of an integral type, but something that satisfies the integral concept. There's not really a way to express that in the concepts that we have
被满足。所以概念的想法是说，我们仍然可以拥有严格的语义。我们所做的是将这些语义与一个名称关联起来。如果你使用这个名称，那么你必须保证你满足这些语义。如果你确实满足了这些语义，那么操作就会按指定工作。但是的，所以随着时间的推移，这些语义已经被剥离了。所以就像我说的，std::find 不再要求相等。它只要求该运算符……你知道，很多这些概念，很多概念是你想要说“我想要一个可以接受单个参数的 invocable，该参数是一个整数”。所以不是整数类型的特定实例，而是满足整数概念的东西。在今天的概念中，没有办法表达这一点。
today. Instead, what you can say is you can say I want something that satisfies invocable with this particular integral type. But that problem of sort of, I think often in the C++OX model, it was called archetypes. It's very hard to check for that, to check, hey, does this thing satisfy the invocable constraints for anything that satisfies this other set of constraints yes yes and uh yeah and and where this you know the the damage that i think this has done with with move is in the old a you know hp and and and sgi st. For people who don't know, the STL was originally developed in HP Labs and so the the very first prototype of STL was done at HP Labs and then Alex moved to SGI and so one of the early popular standard conformant implementations of the STL came out of SGI. So you can still
相反，你可以说的是，我想要满足具有此特定整数类型的 invocable 的东西。但那种……我认为在 C++0x 模型中，它被称为原型（archetypes）。很难检查这一点，检查“嘿，这个东西是否满足任何满足这组其他约束的东西的 invocable 约束”。是的，是的，而且……我认为这在 move 上造成的损害是，在旧的 HP 和 SGI STL 中……对于不知道的人，STL 最初是在 HP 实验室开发的，所以 STL 的第一个原型是在 HP 实验室完成的，然后 Alex 搬到了 SGI，所以早期流行的标准兼容 STL 实现之一来自 SGI。所以你仍然可以……
find the docs for that online. Somebody scraped them from the SGI website when SGI took them down. If you look at the at the old docs and even the the old versions of the standard, there was this notion of the domain of an operation. And basically what that said is that the concept, you know, say a concept of a quality comparable, only has to hold for the values that are reachable through the arguments to the function. So if you're talking about stood find, equality didn't have to be defined as total for all possible values of the arguments passed, only for the values that were reachable, you know, within the range of where you were finding elements. And that's how Alex kind of dealt with NANDs and double precision.
在网上找到它的文档。当 SGI 将它们撤下时，有人从 SGI 网站上抓取了它们。如果你看旧文档，甚至旧版本的标准，都有“操作域”的概念。基本上它说的是，概念，你知道，比如“相等可比较”的概念，只需要对通过函数参数可达的值成立。所以如果你在谈论 std::find，相等性不需要定义为对传递的所有可能的参数值都是总的，只需要对可达的值成立，你知道，在你寻找元素的范围内。这就是 Alex 处理浮点数 NaN 的方式。
So, you know, less than is required to be a strict weak ordering. Less than on floating point types is not a strict weak ordering if you consider NaN. And so Alex just took NaN out of the domain of the operation, right? And being outside the domain of the operation doesn't mean that it has undefined behavior for a specific type. It just means that in the use of the algorithms, it no longer satisfies the precondition for the algorithm. And so that's how things like NAND got dealt with. In the case of MOVE, because now the domain of operation still appears in the standard, but it only does for operator equal equal on input iterators, which is like really weird. It's been like stripped every place else and now there's just one section
所以，你知道，小于（less than）被要求是严格弱序。如果考虑 NaN，浮点类型上的小于不是严格弱序。所以 Alex 只是把 NaN 从操作域中拿走了，对吧？并且在操作域之外并不意味着它对特定类型具有未定义行为。它只是意味着在算法的使用中，它不再满足算法的前置条件。这就是 NaN 之类的东西被处理的方式。在 MOVE 的情况下，因为现在操作域仍然出现在标准中，但它只对输入迭代器上的 operator== 有效，这真的很奇怪。它在其他地方都被剥离了，现在只有一个部分……
where we talk about domain of operation for equal equal for input iterators. The reason why that affects move is basically what happens is when I move one object from one location to another location, the value that's been moved from is only required to be in an unspecified state, and that unspecified state has to be removed from the domain for most of the other operations. And basically, my proposed wording is to say, you know, it's removed from the domain of all operations except for being used in the left hand side of assignment and destruction. Right.
我们谈论输入迭代器的 operator== 的操作域。这影响 move 的原因基本上是，当我将一个对象从一个位置移动到另一个位置时，被移动的对象只需要处于未指定状态，并且该未指定状态必须从大多数其他操作的域中移除。基本上，我提议的措辞是说，你知道，它从所有操作的域中移除，除了被用作赋值和销毁的左侧。对吧。
Right. But it's a challenge because domain of operation isn't used anymore in the standard. That's where we'll end Part 1. Tune in next week for Part 2. Have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对吧。但这很有挑战性，因为操作域在标准中不再使用了。我们将在第 1 部分结束。下周请收听第 2 部分。祝你有美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。